of course I'm extremely interested in
the biological aspects of Donald Trump
Hillary Clinton and Bernie Sanders well
Trump is all testosterone this is why
Putin likes them they're out of the same
mold I mean they come in from different
countries they speak different languages
they probably have different things for
breakfast but bottom line is the
temperament is exactly the same Putin
will understand Trump if in fact Trump
becomes president and Trump will be able
to probably deal with Putin now I hope
that both of them aren't so low on
impulse control that people push the
button at the wrong minute I mean
there's there's great benefits to
dealing with somebody who's exactly like
you really in terms of temperament but
there's also you know great problems I
mean the high testosterone kind of
person is impulsive they say what they
mean they say it right now they trample
on people's feelings because being
honest is more important than being kind
they are not great negotiators and we
live in a modern world in which
negotiation is in my opinion absolutely
essential of course he's a builder and
that's spatial relations and that's
testosterone too so the tough mindedness
and the analytical spatial understanding
is all high testosterone and that's
Donald Trump I think Hillary Clinton is
also high testosterone she's direct
she's decisive she's somewhat more like
um but she also has quite a mix of the
estrogen she cares very much for women
and for women's rights Bernie Sanders
seems to be very expressive of the
estrogen system he's all loving and
caring and all these young people who
like him I think they like him because
they feel he's a grandfather Putin won't
understand him and he won't understand
Putin they are marching to different
drummers the more socially skilled of
course is Bernie Sanders and very often
a high
person can run circles around the high
testosterone prison because they're so
skilled at negotiating it and working
things out so I wouldn't say that Trump
would be any better at getting something
done with Putin then Sanders but they're
going to do it in a very different way
and Putin will not understand Bernie
Sanders any more than he understands
Barack Obama because if Barack Obama
also has that those verbal skills the
people skills the the compassion the
subtlety the new ones the caring of the
high estrogen kind of person and
somebody like Putin doesn't get that
you